we got there uh of course we're pretty
excited the ticket agent went on to tell
us there was no flight from Vancouver to
Maui and there hadn't been for some time
a shock for the Sherlocks their annual
trip to Maui wasn't a go at least not
that October day I really can't put that
was going through my mind at least not
with Air Canada I was really upset and
really frustrated when she basically
tried to blow us off and said you'll
have to deal with airlan on this there
were so many things that were so wrong
on so many levels Sharon and Jim
Sherlock don't believe they did anything
wrong they had their tickets and
Confirmation what they didn't have
according to Air Canada the notice the
airline says it sent of an itinerary
change they sent me nothing nothing we
never received anything to go to San
Francisco nothing through United at all
and they just said we did that and you
didn't reply so we canceled it in many
cases passengers are being Stonewood by
the airlines Gabor lucat with Eric
passenger rights says Airline complaints
have soared the Canadian Transportation
agency confirming there's a backlog of
upwards of 62,000 complaints but it adds
it's hired and trained extra workers
designed a new digitalized complaint
System created online materials and
launched a new online portal lcat says
these are not Solutions what is cracking
down on airlines the government uh was
given
additional Powers by Parliament to pass
on the costs of these complaints to the
Airlines and to impose much higher fines
on airlines but the government dropped
the ball they just said that's too bad
the Sherlocks did make it to Maui
rebooking on WestJet for 1,400 they've
gotten some money and points back but
won't rest until they get the rest the
airlines can do whatever they want now
they there is no responsibility to the
public and they really do not
care